good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we have sad news writer
physician and longtime Fox contributor
Charles Krauthammer died today at the
age of 68 he leaves behind his beloved
wife Robbie whom he married in 1974 and
their son Daniel also mourning his death
tonight are his many friends at this
network and the millions of viewers who
knew and loved Charles from watching him
every night and they did ask any Fox
anchor who's the person people you meet
at the airport asked about the most and
every single one of them will tell you
Charles Krauthammer
Fox viewers loved Charles and it wasn't
because he pandered to them he never did
that sometimes in fact he took positions
that they disliked or even hated but if
you errs not only forgave him for doing
that they seemed to love him more they
could see his brilliance but they could
also feel his sincerity Charles always
said what he thought was true he was an
honest and genuinely decent man and it
shone through it was not opposed Charles
also may be the bravest man I ever met
personally it takes courage to stay
cheerful and humane for anyone for 68
years and doubly so given the remarkable
challenges that he faced for the last 44
of those years but he did it
Charles was totally unintimidating all
the way through brave and clear thinking
to the end what a man